why does a woman need a man that's what
i mean they just don't realize it yet
because you try surviving on your own
without a man
you cannot wake up in the morning and go
through your whole day without having to
rely on a man for something like what
like everything around them wherever you
go you get your petrol or wherever you
go and you get the bus whether you the
the the clothes that you wear in the
shop the designer you cannot get through
life without a man
men built the world
like they they do all of the hard jobs
in society everything that makes the
infrastructure run
i'm not saying we don't need men that's
not my view at all but i just feel like
this is what this is like that term left
over i feel like the things you're
saying
and the over reliance on men that's what
perpetuates that view because it makes
it seem like a woman literally can't
survive without a man and i feel like
you're linking that like one thing you
mentioned earlier you said that there's
a link between divorce rates and um
when women were able to get access to
birth control and i feel like
in terms of marriage like when you're
when you're equating marriage with
that's when a woman's gonna have kids
and
she's gonna take some of the man's
income in that sense i feel like
um
i've lost my point now i forgot what i
said to you a lot of i feel like
there's a lot of feelings is there any
do you come from a place of logic or is
this all feeling
what do you think is feeling like how
can you so what do you think is feeling
no because you say i feel like i feel
like i feel like so i was just wondering
if you're saying that i do want me to
say i don't know no no i don't know i'm
is it all feeling if you tell me you're
feeling then
i don't think it's feeling this is what
i mean i feel like women have
what do you want me to say
yeah right
so um yeah from what you said about
divorce rates and birth control i feel
like that's where women have gained
power in terms of
they don't necess they're not burdened
financially
um so they're free to leave they're free
to leave marriages and i feel like
that's another reason why i said
um
i feel like our generation is changing
so women are we are becoming more
independent because
it's not the same like
no offense but like compared to now and
30 years ago the amount of women that
are educated and then
because they're more educated they have
access to higher paying roles
more dirt though they have more dirt
okay okay but that's i would say
what leaves women in
a bad place financially
is kids
and because we have access to birth
control now that's what i mean by i feel
like we have power and i wouldn't go to
the extreme of saying a woman needs a
man but i wouldn't also go to the
extreme of saying
a woman can't live without a man i feel
like there's an in-between
but you shouldn't use extremes i think
it's extremely easy to say that
then if he was young
and then you had a child
and then you say you didn't need the man
you'd be all right raising a child on
your own because you wouldn't need a man
you just got your child
whereas you might not think that you
need a man when you've got a child but
actually you do but you won't realize
that until you see the consequences for
your life from through your child's life
because when women have children
it's all right to say i'm gonna leave
the marriage because you're gonna leave
the marriage with the child the house
the car his money you don't have to work
again
so when you're saying that women have
the power from like way back when
because i'm the oldest so way back when
in my day
i wanted when i had to go to um
when you go to school and they say what
you want to do when you grow up and you
go and see the officer
two things i wanted to be
either a housewife or a lorry driver
and she told me those are the two most
stupid things she ever heard and come
out that room and all through my life
all i wanted to be was a housewife and
all of my friends thought it was crazy
that was the worst job ever but some of
the most successful couples i know
is with the woman at home because she
the man brings everything in
but
i can see you smiling as a young person
there's nothing wrong being
a housewife and having your side hustle
i wouldn't you can have your side hustle
you can have your own business you can
have your own law firm you can have
everything like that and still be a
housewife and when young people look at
it like oh there's something wrong with
being a housewife
wait till you're 35 and you're on your
own and there's no man and it's just you
and your pets
and then you're gonna think i've got my
degree i've traveled i've done this i've
got my house i've got my business who
are you going to travel with your old
friends
your old female friends because nobody
of any status is going to want to travel
with you especially if you've got
children so you might think that things
were different back in the day
but things were actually better back in
the day because people got married i am
one person i believe until death do you
part you shouldn't be allowed to get
divorced somebody should have to die
before you get divorced because that's
what it says till death do you part and
if more people were into marriage
thinking you know what
get counselling
let me go and do this
talk to my elders talk to my parents
then get more successful marriages and
it wouldn't seem so bad as a young
person
i agree with you i'm not against
marriage i don't have anything against
marriage but i'm just realistic at um in
terms of generation we're in i feel like
that's where a lot of the things you're
saying i disagree
um
and another thing that i feel like
you're saying you need a man for is when
you have a child which i understand
because parenting is a two it's for two
people it's not for one person
regardless of if you're a man or a woman
you need two people to parent however i
wouldn't say that
a woman needs like what you're saying
about so you're saying a woman that's 35
she's done a lot like in terms of
financially she's had a lot of life
experiences but she's not with a man
you're saying her life is unsuccessful
just because she's not gone i'm not
saying that i'm saying she'd be
successful but will she be satisfied i
won't she'd be lonely or she won't be
lonely what are you gonna do when it
comes to 50 and you're on your own 60
when you own 70 when you're on your own
and if you intend to be on your own like
say 35 if you can say right you know
what i'm not going to settle down to my
35 start planning your pension start
planning that when you're old or you're
disabled or you can't manage yourself
who's going to look after you you might
as well start planning these things
ahead because a lot of people don't look
ahead like that but if you had a husband
and you're married pensions and all them
things so if you're going to be like
enjoying your life now i had my pension
at 18 so i was different i was when
there was early people but you need to
start planning i have a pension early
that's good you need to start planning
early
and think about property and not travel
in and things like that then i can say
well if you're going to be on your own
fine but be happy on your own but can
you be happy on your own at 60 70 80.
and that's the one thing just to back
what she's saying up the least happy
group of women is women over the age of
45 that have that are single and
childless that make over 47 thousand
dollars per year
but that's not what i'm saying i'm not
advocating for a woman that's childless
and she doesn't have a partner at 40.
i'm just saying just because
you don't have someone at 35 doesn't
mean you keep going to 60 and 70. again
go into extremes
i'm 53. that's not extreme no but you
keep mentioning six talking to your mind
talking about you keep mentioning 60 70.
that's extreme from 35. but that's cause
you don't you don't go from you haven't
mentioned okay a woman at 40.
you're jumping you're jumping years
that's what i'm saying i'm saying just
because my point is to begin with just
because you're 35 and you're single
doesn't mean you'll be single at 40 at
60 at 70. but the problem is at 35
you've lost all the things that men
value that that's the problem because
men